ein riesiger roter rock den wir da sehen
das ist lady gaga sie war vorhin
natürlich schon angekündigt sie wird
jetzt die nationalhymne singen und da
hat joe biden und sein team auf jeden
fall einen der größten superstars der
welt weiß ich jetzt unter wollen wir
jeden moment groß sehen von lady gaga
sie trifft jetzt auf joe biden dort und
auf kamalla herres sie wird gleich als
erste eingeschworen als vize-präsidentin
bevor es dann zur inauguration freundes
mikrofon für die nationalhymne jetzt
also
[Musik]
busemann
so wie er
nein
das ist
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren